Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated back
here on the show how you been Chris
going on rich so the before we get to
the the the main course with Kawhi and
everything else what's the one free
agent signing we're not talking about
because it's been lost amongst the
Durant teaming up with Kyrie what's
Kawhi gonna do hoopla Chris you mean if
ours guys that have son yes sir the
signing that has occurred over the last
48 hours that's not getting nearly
enough attention would be I mean there's
some that are getting the right amount
of attention I mean what Utah's done not
just in the last 48 hours but the last
few days and have a week plus I mean
they really fortified themselves as a
legit Conference contender I mean if you
if you look at the one thing that was
missing from that team last year it was
kind of for spacing around Donovan
Mitchell
because in year two everyone kind of you
know figured out how to defend the Jazz
and they needed more scoring and they
got it with Mike Conley who had a great
bounce-back season last year I mean they
went out and really blew the doors off
bullion Bogdanovich he was you know they
gave him a huge offer to sign there and
now they have the makings of a really
competitive team in the Western
Conference one that as we speak right
now I think you'd have to rank
immediately amongst the favorites in the
conference what are the Warriors doing
what's happening with with Russell the
acquisition of him their plans for him
and their plans moving forward here in
their post Durant world well I think
it's twofold with the Angela Russell I
mean first they need bodies out there I
mean they need somebody to play minutes
out there I mean they're I mean the
injuries and the losses that they've
incurred in free agency and trades have
left them kind of with a skeleton crew
and Russell's a guy that's used to
playing you know 30 35 maybe even 40
minutes a night so they need some
somebody that can can play really until
klay Thompson is healthy and then you
know kind of see what happens the rest
of this year as far as the long-term I
don't know that they've entirely
committed them
to a Russell curry you know Thompson you
know 300 monster in their backcourt and
small horde position I think there's
some some serious issues with that type
of team it's very very small and I'm not
sure how you you defend at a high enough
level at that those positions but you
know Russell's very tradable I mean he's
a guy that's proven himself as an
all-star point guard if you go into year
two you're only gonna have three years
left in his contract and if you decide
to trade him next summer it's one of the
weaker free agent classes that we've
we've seen in a while with really only
draymond Green lurking out there as as a
top guy you can get something back in
return so I get it with the Warriors on
on acquiring D'Angelo Russell so so good
for 2019-20
looking over the steering wheel he is a
commodity to be flipped who who would be
interested in him even right now just
say you get a whole bunch of players
back for him and you can get the bodies
that you're requiring for a Golden State
right now Chris
well Minnesota would and the
Timberwolves I'm not exactly sure what
went down out there but the Timberwolves
are pretty shell-shocked
in the aftermath of the Russell deal
they thought they had something worked
out with the Angela Russell that was
going to you know move some pieces
around for them and put him in that mix
alongside
karl-anthony towns as how their
two-headed monster moving forward and
that's a team that you know as they move
forward and depending on what happens to
them that's someone that could be very
interested down the line Russell we've
got Chris Maddox on the horn right here
from Sports Illustrated and you do a ton
of work in the Boston area relating with
the Celtics what is what is the Danny
Ainge plan here now with it gets a Kemba
Walker no Kyrie no more Horford world
what does this team look like well I
think they salvage the off season as
best they could I mean they they missed
on Anthony Davis Kyrie left
yeah Horford once things I think more
than than the other two because I don't
think they view the other two as as
being as likely to happen as Al Horford
being back and having him go to a
division rival a conference rival makes
that cut near double EB
without Horford but you know getting
Kemba Walker I think overall you know
when you factor in the locker room stuff
is going to be an upgrade over over
Kyrie Irving I think Kemba has at least
a couple maybe three more really high
level years left in him so now what
they've got to focus on is going out and
fortifying that frontcourt I mean and
his cancer is nice but he doesn't defend
anybody and defensive strength was was
one of their strengths
last year they just signed a kid I guess
from France I don't know too much about
him but I wouldn't put too much stock in
in somebody brought in over strim
overseas on a short-term deal they've
got to go up there and whether it's
trade or off kind of the scrapheap of
free agents to get somebody else
upgrade that frontcourt to put
themselves at least in the mix be a
threat in the conference Chris Mannix
Sports Illustrated here in the Rich
Eisen show let's get to the meat of the
potatoes here Kawhi Leonard what are you
hearing not a lot to be honest and it's
not all that surprising since Kawhi
Leonard does not like his business
getting out there and if you're a team
that's in contention for Kawhi Leonard
you're not going to hold a guy and and
and let that let you know any kind of
leak that gets traced back to you be a
factor in all this so the team's I've
talked to either are not talking to me
or not saying much back in return so
it's the three teams we're talking about
you know the Lakers and Clippers have
put themselves in a really tough spot
here because if Kawhi Leonard elects to
go back in Toronto I don't know what
they do because the free agent market is
drying up you know very quickly and
those guys that are out there that could
make an impact next year especially for
the Lakers who don't have any trade
assets left either
it's problematic so the ripple effects
of the decision Kawhi let her make are
gonna be enormous throughout the NBA
they sure are I mean that's how we
started the show Chris is that you could
make the case he was the number one
factor in who won the NBA Finals this
year and he's the number one factor in
who wins the NBA Finals next year I mean
there's no other person you could say
that about when it's all said no no
there there really isn't he's you know
you put him on the Clippers and who just
got Patrick Beverley back and had some
really nice pieces there and a gaping
hole at that three spot you can make an
argument that the Clippers are the top
team in the Western [ __ ] you put him
back on Toronto and they're clearly the
favorite to repeat next year so yeah he
it's more about the Lakers really rich I
mean and I don't blame them I talk to a
lot of NBA people about this and to a
man they all said if they thought they
had a shot at Kawhi Leonard they would
roll the dice and wait this thing out I
don't blame him for doing this but man
if they don't get him you know you're
talking maybe DeMarcus Cousins in that
mix I don't even know I mean they're
there guys signing by the hour that I
know the Lakers had at least one eye on
and and it's not going to leave them
with much back in return
mhmmm so ask the poll question of Chris
Mannix there Chris Brockman go for it
yeah Chris what's the best move for the
NBA Kauai stays in Toronto joins the
Lakers joins the Clippers you you put
the Commissioner on sodium pentathol he
gives which answer I think Kawhi staying
with Toronto is it at least it fits with
the mindset I know Adam silver has the
NBA they hate super teams they do they
you know it does draw ratings in the
playoffs especially but the NMB a and
Adam Silver's regime particularly has so
badly craved NBA style parity and if you
put Kawhi with the Lakers you might have
the best super team ever if they can
flush out the roster in the coming years
with three guys that you can you can
easily argue ranked in the top ten in
the NBA as players the NB a-- doesn't
really want that even though having a
glamour team in LA is good for ratings
it's not good for parody you know
putting Kawhi back in Toronto then they
wouldn't walk to the finals in the East
they're too much competition there for
that to happen but it makes the Raptors
competitive the Clippers still have the
assets to figure something out I mean
they have a bunch of draft picks and
some tradable pieces where they can make
another move I just think you know Kawhi
goes back to the Raptors next season
begins with like I don't know eight
teams that probably think they have a
realistic chance of winning a
championship and that's exactly what
Adam Silver's always wanted yeah I mean
I agree with you I think so many fans
would be upset if Kawhi created this
that you're talking about I really do
especially since we we have made it
through what would you say about a
10-year stretch of the super team era
from the heat what they did to what the
Warriors did with Durant to supplant the
one time that they lost to LeBron with
Love and Kyrie that we we made it
through this era with the Raptors
getting Kawhi and doing what obviously
Oklahoma City hoped with Paul George and
there was no Russell Westbrook if you
will with all due respect to Lowry and
Van Vleet and and the rest of that
dynamic team I think the fans would just
be I'm looking like we've even mentioned
the Blazers to Chris you know so I think
so many fans would be disappointed if
that happens really and yeah I agree the
only thing I could say about Hawaii is
I'd have told people this said I've done
I think three magazine profiles on him I
don't know the guy at all
that's amazing he's just impossible to
really get to know on a personal level
but if he went to the Lakers it would be
it would be against pretty much
everything I know about him and what I
do know is that Kauai believes that he's
when he steps on the floor he believes
he's the best player and he believes
whatever team he's on has a chance to
win a championship and should be
including the mix to where the
championship that's why the Clippers
make some sense because it would be his
team they built that team with you know
great supporting cast players to put
around the Alpha and Kawhi Leonard the
Raptors are his team no matter what Ron
James says to him and Anthony Davis
might say to him it's not gonna be his
team and we've not fir for a few years
and and and that will always be the case
as long as LeBron is in that mix that's
why it I get you know the Lakers the
marquee team and I don't and the one
thing we don't know is what's really
important to Kawhi Leonard and that's
always the biggest variable when you're
trying to figure out free agency but
going to the Lakers would would surprise
the only in the sense that it just
doesn't think up to everything I do know
about Goliath Chris loved the chat
thanks for the call really appreciate it
we'll chat
later on this summer no question about
it thanks you got a rich you got it
that's Chris Mannix of Sports
Illustrated for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app